I have a series of tweets that I tweet
frequently where I just you know I I say
some I tweet things that I kind of feel
are like they should be cancelable
things like like I tweeted several times
have you considered spaying and
neutering your kids to prevent
overpopulation and I've tweeted things
like the the upside to abortion is that
there's too many children and we need
less people on the planet like these
should be things that ever like anyone
ever said seriously people should be
like whoa whoa whoa come on but there's
not not only does it break no rules on
Twitter to ask people to like consider
sterilizing their children
there's no outrage from the media at all
I was thinking about this I was like I
bet if I tweet things like war is good
because there's too many people they
will they will completely ignore it if I
tweet it's great that children are being
sterilized they'll completely lo and
behold the media doesn't care one bit
there's no smears no cancellation I just
I don't know what their intent is but
for whatever reason everything is
pointing in One Direction these actions
will result in much less people